are living in a time of nearly
unprecedented uncertainty there's the
pandemic there's political upheaval
there's the economy is it going to go up
and down we don't know 87 of adults out
there say it feels like there's been a
constant stream of crises over the last
two years and i agree that's according
to a survey by the american
psychological association
73 meanwhile say they feel overwhelmed
by these crises and all this uncertainty
and change can have a very big impact on
our mental health for more on that we've
got social psychologist heidi grant here
to explain what this uncertainty is
doing to our brains and how to cope with
the fear that often comes along with it
uncertainty and that's exactly how it
works right you don't know what's going
to happen until you're afraid of what's
going to happen exactly and i think it's
so important for people to realize that
our brains were just not built for this
right we for most of human history were
hunter gatherers our lives were
relatively simple predictable we focused
on what was happening here and now and
maybe a little bit into the future now
we live in a radically different
environment right so much change so much
information so much uncertainty and our
brains were actually designed to sort of
find that threatening and so what
happens is our brains are constantly in
a state of threat we have we struggle to
problem solve we struggle to plan we get
overwhelmed by our emotions we lose our
ability to control our impulses we
actually struggle to learn new things
and to pull things from our memory when
we need it so we're all kind of walking
around feeling
kind of terrible feeling like we're not
at our best and i think it's so
important for people to realize you know
sometimes we blame ourselves for that
but it really has to do with the fact
that our brains just weren't built to
handle what we're being we're dealing
with kind of terrible never seems like a
good state to me heidi no so help us out
what we can do sure what can we do what
should we do yeah there are a few things
that you can do that to kind of help you
manage your day-to-day one is to really
kind of pay attention to what you're
paying attention to i think the more we
focus on the here and now the nearer
future right what you're going to do
today tomorrow next week this month and
not a year from now two years from now
five years from now can help us to sort
of restore
that sense of control also focusing on
what you can do something about rather
than what you can't do anything about i
think so many of us feel now there's so
much we feel powerless about out of
control but every one of us has parts of
our lives where we can do something to
make our own lives a little better make
someone else's life a little better
focus there and it helps us to restore
balance that's a very helpful list i
noticed you didn't have on the list turn
your back to the children and eat two
cookies
i mean
does that work it works yeah it's a
great moment of zen for for a parent
yeah do you know there's actually
research that shows when we feel
uncertain we focus more on our wants
than on our shoulds so we we do kind of
go for the cookie uh rather than maybe
the healthier snack and it's a good
thing to know to kind of push temptation
things out of the way a little bit when
we're feeling uncertain let's talk about
fear because fear is a big part of it
how can people manage the fear that
comes with the i don't know what's going
to happen
i mean
there's actually i mean some of it is
acceptance some of it is sort of getting
a little bit used to it but one really
powerful technique that psychologists
have studied for a long time is simply
labeling your emotion this is something
anybody can do it's incredibly powerful
when you're kind of feeling a little bit
upset just pause for a second and say
what is it that i'm feeling i'm feeling
anxious i'm feeling tense i'm feeling
frustrated i'm feeling angry there's
actually neuroscience studies that show
that simply labeling your emotion
actually starts to bring down the
intensity of the motion all by itself
and that's something we can all be doing
all the time yeah because you're working
with i don't know what's going to happen
or you're also thinking something bad is
about to happen that's quite often a lot
of the stuff we worry about doesn't come
true absolutely and i think that that's
another thing i often talk to people
about is sort of think about the odds
right sometimes we we sort of get really
worked up about the things that might
happen but we don't pause and think well
you know what are the chances that it
will and that again is one of those
things like labeling that can really
kind of bring down the emotion all right
heidi grant thank you for coming you bet
need a little calm this morning